♪ ♪
>> Laura: DEMOCRATS IN THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE HELD A
HEARING WEDNESDAY ON NEW
GUN-CONTROL LEGISLATION THAT
THEY HOPE TO PUSH ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE TOP REPUBLICAN ON THE
COMMITTEE ASKED DEMOCRATS OF
CONGRESSMAN STEVE SCALISE,
HIMSELF A VICTIM OF GUN
VIOLENCE, AND A PROPONENT OF
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS, COULD
TESTIFY ABOUT HIS UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE.
DEMOCRATS DENIED HIM THE
OPPORTUNITY.
WE REACHED OUT TO THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE BECAUSE IT
SOUNDED LIKE IT CAN'T BE TRUE,
AND WE GOT A COMMENT BACK
TONIGHT.
TO THEIR CREDIT, THEY DID
RESPOND, SAYING "THE REPUBLICANS
CHOSE TWO OTHER WITNESSES OTHER
THAN SCALISE BUT SCALISE'S
TESTIMONY WILL BE ENTERED INTO
THE RECORD."
YOU CAN SPEND 10 MINUTES LETTING
THEM TESTIFY?
YOUR NOW WITH STEVE SCALISE, HOW
DO YOU RESPOND TO THEIR PUSHBACK
ON THE NARRATIVE TONIGHT?
>> IT WAS PRETTY BIZARRE.
HISTORICALLY, WHEN REPUBLICANS
WERE IN CHARGE, WIND DEMOCRATS
WERE IN CHARGE, AS A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS WANTED TO TESTIFY ON A
COMMITTEE, THEY ALWAYS PROVIDED
A VENUE, THAT COULD HAPPEN.
IN THIS CASE, HAVING A HEARING
IN THE JUDICIARY ON REDUCING GUN
VIOLENCE.
I'VE GOT A PERSPECTIVE, CLEARLY
MINE DEALT WITH SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED TO ME, AND I SAW HOW
GOODS WERE USED TO SAVE PEOPLE'S
LIVES.
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO BE
PART OF THE TESTIMONY.
THEY WANTED TO FOCUS ON TAKING
AWAY THE RIGHTS OF LAW-ABIDING
CITIZENS.
THEY ARE ULTIMATELY DOES NOT.
SO BECAUSE MY PRESENTATION WOULD
HAVE BEEN --
>> Laura: IT WOULD'VE BEEN
VERY DRAMATIC.
MY QUESTION IS, AGAIN, EVERYONE
WATCHING, THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT
HOUSE PROCEDURES.
BOGGED DOWN THERE.
WHY DIDN'T DOUG COLLINS, THE
RANKING MEMBER, ASSIST YOU GO
FIRST?
IF I'M THE RANKING MEMBER, NO
ONE STOPS YOU FROM TESTIFYING.
I DON'T GET WHAT HE DID -- NO
ONE IS BETTER THAN YOU.
I AM BIASED.
>> ULTIMATELY, HE WANTED ME TO
BE ABLE TO TESTIFY AS WELL BUT
IN THE END, IF THE DEMOCRATS
WANT TO -- I WILL SAY THIS,
NANCY PELOSI TRIED TO RESCIND
THE PRESIDENT'S ABILITY TO GIVE
THE STATE OF THE UNION.
>> Laura: YOU ARE SAYING THIS
IS PATTY.
>> THIS IS HOW THEY ARE PLAYING.
THEY THINK THEY CAN SILENCE
CONSERVATIVE VOICES.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THEY CAN'T SILENCE OUR VOICES.
WE WILL GET THIS MESSAGE OUT.
GO READ THEIR BILL, HR 8.
IF YOU LOAN YOUR SHOTGUN TO A
FRIEND OF YOURS TO GO HUNTING,
UNDER SURGEON'S OR
CIRCUMSTANCES, YOU COULD GO TO
JAIL FOR A YEAR AND HAVE A
$100,000 FINE.
>> Laura: IF YOU OWN A SHOTGUN
SHOTGUN --    --
>> GO READ THEIR BILL.
THEIR BILL WOULD UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES ACTUALLY ALLOW
THAT TO BE A FELONY WHERE YOU
COULD GET A YEAR IN PRISON AND
$100,000 FINE.
BASICALLY IF THEY THINK IT WAS
PART OF A GUN TRANSACTION, IF
YOU SELLING YOUR GUN OR LOANING
YOUR GUN TO SOMEBODY ELSE.
THE GUN-CONTROL IS WHAT THEY ARE
TRYING TO GET OUT.
THEY WANT FULL-GROWN
REGISTRATION, TAKE AWAY YOUR
RIGHTS.
BY THE WAY, IF THERE ABOUT WOULD
HAVE PASSED, WOULD HAVE DONE
NOTHING TO STOP THE SHOOTING
THAT HAPPENED IN MY CASE,
PARKLAND, A LOT OF THESE OTHER
TRAGEDIES.
THEY WANT TO TAKE AWAY THE
RIGHTS OF LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS
TO HAVE A GUN.
THEY ARE TRYING TO HIDE BEHIND,
WE DON'T WANT RIGHTS TAKEN AWAY,
WE WANT TO LIMIT GUN VIOLENCE.
>> Laura: BIT BY BIT, CHIP IT
AWAY.
>> WE WILL CALL THEM OUT ON IT.
THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO SILENCE
THESE VOICES.
LET THEM PLAY THESE SITUATED
HAVE KANGAROO COURTS BUT IN THE
OUTCOME OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE --
>> Laura: I KNOW THEY THINK
IT'S A WINNER, NEVER A WINNER.
THE "UNDER GOD."
EXPLAIN THIS VERY QUICKLY.
NOW JERRY NADLER WENT WITH --
WAS AT THE RESOURCE COUNCIL --
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE?
DEMOCRATS WHO WANTED THE "WILL
HELP ME GOD" TAKEN OUT OF
SWEARING SOMEONE IN?
>> SOMETHING NEW THAT DEMOCRATS
ARE DOING IN THEIR MAJORITY.
EVERY HOUSE COMMITTEES AT THEIR
OWN RULES AND THEIR ROLES FOR US
WEARING A PERSON IN.
THE COMMITTEE OR NATURAL
RESOURCES LAST WEEK LITERALLY
TRIED TO CHANGE THEIR SWEARING
AN OATH THAT THEY TAKE TO REMOVE
THE PHRASE "SO HELP ME GOD."
>> Laura: WHAT ARE THEY
WORRIED ABOUT?
>> REPUBLICANS OBJECTED AND THEY
PUT IF I CAN.
THEY TRIED TO SNEAK IT THROUGH.
IN THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
TODAY, THEY TRIED TO DO THE SAME
THING THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE.
THEY LITERALLY TRIED TO TAKE
AWAY THE PHRASE "SO HELP ME GOD
GOD," REPUBLICANS CALLED THEM
OUT ON IT, MIKE JOHNSON IN THIS
CASE BUT THESE ARE DEMOCRATS
THAT ARE NOW CHAIRING
COMMITTEES, THIS IS PELOSI'S
MAJORITY.
ALL THOSE DEMOCRATS WHO WON
SAYING THEY ARE PRO-LIFE,
PRO-GUN, AGAINST PELOSI, THEY
ELECTED NANCY PELOSI IS BIGGER,
AND NOW THEY ARE TRYING TO TAKE
AWAY GOD, SILENCE VOICES, TRYING
TO TAKE AWAY YOUR GUN RIGHTS.
THIS IS ONLY IN THEIR FIRST
MONTH, LAURA.
EVERYBODY PAY CLOSE ATTENTION.
WHAT DONALD TRUMP DID LAST NIGHT
TO LAY THE FOUNDATION FOR WHAT
WE NEED TO DO TO GET OUR COUNTRY
BACK AND TO REJECT SOCIALISM AND
THEY WOULDN'T EVEN STAND UP TO